でしょうか はい  雰囲気の話なんですが
お釈迦様はもう今いらっしゃらない
仏陀じゃないんですが
法は雰囲気が雰囲気で法はあるし
それからサンガもそのままで雰囲気わかりますが
お釈迦様の雰囲気というのは
お釈迦様がいらっしゃったところに訪ねて行くと感じられる
それも一つとしてね もうお釈迦様もね
やっぱり生まれたところとね
悟ったところとかね 最初の説法したところと涅槃に入られたところをできれば行ってみなさいと
で そうで 信仰ある人はブッダのここを感じるんです
観光はね まあ何も感じないかもしれませんですけどね
信仰ある人っていうのは
ものすごい強烈にインパクトを強く感じるんです
でもそれはどちらかというと宗教っぽいところなんですけど
ブッダの教えなんか勉強してみると
なんか生きてる生々しいブッダが強烈に出てくるんですよ
必ず だからもういい加減仏典とか読んでいる人でも心変わるでしょう
私は仏教なんか大嫌いだっても
何言ってるのかこの人はという感じで読んだっても
心は変わります だから
それはブッダの偉大なる影響力なんです
ブッダに逆らうということは誰にもできない
逆らったら自分がもうものすごい恥をかくだけなんです
というか ものすごい損をするんです
そういうことで まあ一応ブッダの言葉を聞くと
まあなんとなく生きてた人間
サカソンがこういうことを言ったのかと
もう一応感じます では
回向の文とかします  回向の文
六道僧の三宝に礼拝致し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして苦悩が減らされますように
サッビーティユーヴィワージャントゥ
サンベローゴーウィナッサトーマーテーバワットワンテラーヨースーティーディーガーユコーバヴァーババトゥサンベマンガランラッカントゥサンバデーワターサンバ
ブッダアヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマアヌバーヴェーナサッベサンガアヌバーヴェーナサダー スッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリッサニッチャンワッダーパチャ
イノーチャッタローダンマワッダンティーヤーユワッノーシュカンバラン
では本当に長い時間どうもありがとうございます